oh man there he goes again criticizing
elon musk
hasn't he heard about the wright
brothers everybody told them that the
flying machine was impossible that
humans couldn't fly like birds in the
sky
and yet despite all the odds and
naysayers they did invent the flying
machine and they revolutionized our
world
the wright brothers were visionary
geniuses
alright so this argument comes up over
and over and over again when anyone dash
to criticize one of elon musk's fever
dreams
and it's kind of correct in the sense
that people did tell the wright brothers
that the flying machine was impossible
and that they did it anyway
and that it went on to revolutionize our
world that all sounds very nice but what
people usually leave out
is that before the wright brothers
success hell even after it
there were dozens if not hundreds of
failed ideas and just
plain dumb concepts and so bringing up
the rug brothers or any other successful
inventors in defense of elon musk
is actually an argument against elon
musk because it shows you that most of
these ideas most of these concepts
will not work and that there will be a
lot of failures before one final success
and so let's talk about the most
excruciatingly stupid idea of elon musk
so far
starship earth to earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and so what's wrong with this concept
what's wrong with the concept of
strapping people to
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
shooting them across the planet
well i mean what's not wrong with it and
so let's go through the main problems
one by one
and the first problem being of course
strapping regular people to [ __ ]
rockets
according to the official spacex
promotional video the max speed of this
thing will be 27
000 kilometers per hour that would be
7500 meters per second which also
happens to be the max speed of
a falcon heavy rocket for example and so
as we can see on this falcon heavy
telemetry graph
in order to reach that top speed the
acceleration goes beyond
three g's and that kind of acceleration
can already cause
things such as falling blood pressure
limited eyesight
muscle cramps difficulty breathing or
blacking out
and this problem cannot be engineered
away really because it stems from humans
biological makeup you know it's nice
when number go big
and number go up but humans haven't
evolved to be flown around in the sky at
3
g's you know in contrast a normal
airplane subjects you to between 0.2 and
0.4 g's
and even that is not recommended for
people with certain medical conditions
so it's safe to assume that only
physically fit able-bodied and healthy
people could take the starship which
already excludes half of the planet's
population pretty much
well so far things do not look good for
the starship
and with that let's go on to problem
number two namely that the rocket will
run
on fossil fuel and so pardon my
ignorance but why do we want to invest
in fossil fuel based transportation
technology in the 21st century
so based on what i've read a suborbital
flight which the starship would do
in case of earth transportation would
require 25 percent of the fuel
of a regular record flights as in going
all the way all right so here we have
this stable with the emissions to
payload mass ratio
and as you can see the starship can haul
100 tons to low earth orbit
and what i've read in the article is
that the co2 payload column actually
specifies the
tonnage of co2 emitted per ton to low
earth orbit so that means that according
to this graph
if we want to take 100 tons to low earth
orbit that would be 2700 tons of co2
now since we're staying suborbital we're
going to apply the 25 percent
and so the number we get for a full
starship at suborbital
flights is 675 tons of co2
that's the approximate amount of co2
emissions if we take these numbers too
hard and so how much does a normal
airplane emit
during a transatlantic flight well turns
out the total emissions of an airplane
between
london and new york is less than one ton
airplanes in general emit
90 kilograms of co2 per hour and so if a
transatlantic flight takes
say 8 hours then we're looking at 720
kilograms of co2
meaning that if you take the starship
between new york and london that would
be an almost
thousand-fold increase in your co2
emissions right so i think i have a
winning idea for elon musk's 100 million
dollar carbon removal competition
don't use [ __ ] rockets for long
distance flights
and so let's move on to problem number
three which is noise
you know rockets have this attribute of
being really [ __ ] loud
and so the launch pads would have to be
really really far from cities
according to the man himself this would
be around 20 miles away from the shore
but if you look at spacex's promotional
video well the thing is right next to
the city meanwhile if you are really 20
miles away from the shore you wouldn't
even be able to see the skyscrapers
the coast itself disappears at 12 miles
and you'll be at 20. now 20 miles is
about 32 kilometers
and let's say we have a pretty fast
ferry to take all the passengers to a
platform like the ms superfast 11
that thing has a top speed of about 50
kilometers per hour and so this ties
into problem number four
logistics that means the ship would need
around 40 minutes or so to get from the
city to the platform
now if we calculate with half an hour
for the passengers to get on and off on
both ends
we are looking at 1 hour and 40 minutes
just to get from the harbor to the
rocket
and in addition to this you have to put
1 000 people through security
you know 1000 being the capacity of the
starship imagined by elon musk
so we can be charitable and say that
would be about an hour and then of
course once you make it to the platform
you would need
at least half an hour to get everyone in
the rocket safely and settle down
plus all the luggage would need to be
loaded in and secured and then once
again this exact same procedure on the
other side
and then we have the half an hour travel
time because let's say we're traveling
between new york and london
and would you look at that just getting
from harbor to harbor takes 6 hours and
50 minutes
assuming there are no delays and nothing
goes wrong anyway and so how does this
measure up to a regular transatlantic
flight
in both cases we assume that we are
already at the entrance when we begin
our journey so namely the harbor and the
airport
so let's assume that if we take a
regular flight we need one and a half
hours on both ends
and so with a 7 hour 45-minute
transatlantic flight that would mean 10
hours and 45 minutes
that's four hours more than taking the
starship and so
have you heard about this thing called
the conquered it's average flight time
between london and new york
was around 3 hours and 30 minutes four
hours less than a regular flight
and would you look at that it's the same
amount of time as taking the starship
except you don't have to subject
yourself to three g's
now as we all know the concord of course
had failed for multiple reasons
but nowadays there are plans for
hypersonic passenger jets
boeing has one for example with a
proposed maximum speed of mach 5.
this would mean that a transatlantic
flight would take two hours
now it's a question whether hypersonic
flight will ever make sense due to
cost and spatial limitations but i still
find it far more likely than
international rocket travel
and with that let's go over to problem
number five the biggest one
safety you know rockets are somewhat
difficult to build but the concept
itself is not complicated
at least not that much i mean you
already had rockets in medieval china in
the 13th century
and modern rockets at the end of the day
aren't that complicated either
so this is what a general rocket looks
like on the inside a picture credit goes
to me
as you can see we have a fuel tank an
oxidizer tank we have two pumps pumping
both the fuel and the oxidizer into the
combustion chamber
that produces thrust and so rocket go
fast now a spacex thruster namely the
newest raptor one is a bit more
complicated
it's a so-called full-flow stage
combustion cycle rocket engine
pictured here the main difference being
is that instead of two
individually powered pumps we have one
turbine which runs the two pumps both
for the fuel and the oxidizer and the
turbine itself is run by fuel rich gas
from the pre-burner
so this spins the fuel and the oxidizer
pumps and then the fuel rich gas is
routed back into the combustion chamber
thus increasing efficiency
you know previously that gas just left
through an exhaust pipe and they
couldn't burn it so that's why it's a
big deal they now can
now believe it or not this is actually
pretty good so congratulations to all
the engineers who worked on this
however as far as i know this still
doesn't solve the fundamental issue with
rocketry and it's the combustion chamber
namely how do you put together fuel and
oxidizer in that little space without
the rocket exploding
it's extremely tricky but now we have it
largely figured out
rockets have indeed gotten much safer to
the point where only 1 in 100 will
explode
meaning your chances of dying are 1 in
100
now with airplanes this number is 1 out
of 5.4
million that means rockets are 54 000
times more dangerous
so in order for the starship to be as
safe as airplanes
you would need to have a single rocket
accident per every
5.4 million rocket flights so what elon
musk is proposing here
is a fossil fuel-based transportation
technology where passengers are
subjected to 3gs
which will shave off four hours of a
transatlantic flight
and all we need to do for this is make
rockets 54 000 times safer
man what a genius what a visionary not
even reality or basic mathematics can
stop him
you know this actually has to be the
dumbest thing that elon musk has ever
come up with
you know with the hyperloop at least
it's not that stupid on the surface and
of course if you dig deeper it turns out
that it's complete horseshit as i
discussed in my previous video
but the starship earth to earth we're
gonna strap people onto rockets and
we're gonna shoot them from new york to
[ __ ] shanghai
i mean do i need to say anything here i
mean i feel like this should just speak
for itself really
but then again this ties perfectly back
to elon musk's major modus operandi
which is to come up with ideas that
people can soy face at
every single thing around elon musk is
dedicated to this singular goal
that's why you have things like
hyperloop gigafactory
cyber truck a big [ __ ] rocket
vibranium
the boring company doggy coin
starship every single one of these names
are designed to elicit this
primitive awe in under-informed news
reporters and to feed into this movement
of scientism in our popular culture
scientism being this essentially worship
of science without ever understanding
any of it
or following any of its principles and
well
that just makes me mad anyway so that
was my take on the big [ __ ] rocket or
lately the starship
i hope you enjoyed it and if you have
any feedback or if i screwed up with the
numbers anywhere please let me know
and in the meantime don't forget to like
and subscribe
and i'll see you when i'll see you